so man with a plan what a frickin 2019
what's the plan I don't know my you're
here at the American Music Awards
sitting in the front row because I saw
your seat card on Friday and then you're
gonna go to the Grammys and sweep thank
you that's very kind of you I feel
really happy to be here and as a just
fan of music in general it's cool to be
amongst tons of musicians so I've loved
for years it's really exciting to be
here what is the secret sauce in there
in this brain I'm very flattered that
anyone thinks there's secret sauce I
think in like in terms of like Kung Fu
Panda or something like there's no
secret people just kind of think there
is I mean mainly I just try to help
artists be really honest and talk about
how they're really feeling and just get
rid of any artifice and get rid of like
pretending to be something or not
someone people to be really honest how
did you hear about the Grammy
nominations where were you that was I
was in bed it was like 6:00 in the
morning and the sunlight woke me up and
I was like gonna go back to sleep and
then I remembered that the nominations
had come out and then I like looked at
him on my phone I was I was nervous
but I felt so lucky to be nominated
amongst everybody else that's so
incredibly talented when did you see
your sister I called her I don't I think
I saw her that and I think we lit off
some fireworks we had left over from the
fourth of July that night celebration
just like alone alone in the backyard
very private it's great yeah big party
listen you've been in this game for a
very long time and you've had a lot of
different shops and worked on a lot of
different things and so I guess my
question is like the Grammys is the
biggest deal in the world so does this
feel like a pinch me moment are you like
I knew I'd always get there or like oh
yeah I think my my dreams as a kid we're
so far below the Grammys you know I mean
like maybe selling out a show was like
the dream or like I don't know seeing
your album on a shelf in like an urban
outfitters or something just places that
I was going in my real life hearing your
song playing at like a restaurant you
like right so the Grammys were so far
above that because the people that were
not in for Grammys were like Adele and
you know stuff that you can't compare
yourself to so sure it's it's very
ridiculous yeah tell me one thing what
do you guys fight about ever cuz I know
that like every time I interview you're
like oh yeah we're screwed whoever it is
I want to know
when do billy and phineas get at each
other we've been fighting about lately
I'm trying to think you know I mean do
you have a sibling you fight about
everything every deal but that's like
the fun part and also like it doesn't
because there's so much love there it
doesn't matter at all and nobody gets
awkward or weird when somebody fights
with like their friend everyone like
tenses up whenever we just disagree
about stuff and then we make each other
laugh pretty much that's it like we're
both like trying to get a point across
and then one of us makes a joke and the
other one laughs and that's it's it it's
over what do you think about just last
thing what do you think about this world
coming out and sort of like idolizing
like when you walk down the street you
see people with the green stripe in
their hair they're like idolizing your
kid sister I think it's awesome
I idolized my kid sister so I get it I
understand why other people do too
[Music]